explíquenos un poco cómo ha marcado la
pandemia las elecciones de francia que
como lo decía es una de las grandes
particularidades que se ve por primera
vez en los comicios presidenciales pues
honestamente para mí es un poco difícil
responder esta pregunta lo que lo que yo
entiendo es que en este momento en el
país las restricciones no son no son
enormes incluso creo que ya casi no hay
un amigo mío me contaba esto hace unos
días de que parecía que la que la que la
pandemia se ha acabado y que cuando en
realidad nunca hubo tantos contagios
ahora bien con la vacuna con con la
vacuna y con digamos ya la resistencia
que se está creando lo más probable es
que la consecuencia directa sobre el
número de votantes no sea enorme la
pandemia impacto más es en el
descontento de las personas porque
cuenta los niveles de los bajos
resultados económicos lo que ha generado
desde dificultades de enojo entre
comillas serie de violencia en la
sociedad en reacción en los últimos
tiempos yo probablemente tienen impactos
más políticos que que sobre los comicios
como tal
probablemente
cambia un poco los pocos los focos de
los focos de impacto y ha obligado a
obligado a los candidatos a tener en
cuenta la salud como un punto más o
menos importante en sus campañas aunque
hemos visto en las últimas semanas en
los meses que la bola ha vuelto digamos
a
adelantarse en el escenario político han
vuelto a adelantarse a otros temas otras
temáticas más clásicas como el poder de
compra la inseguridad y los temas
clásicos de la de las elecciones en
francia y que tan determinantes son los
votos de los franceses que viven en el
exterior como lo veíamos anteriormente
en los comicios de hace cinco años en
2017 cerca de 103 mil personas votaron
para las presidenciales en francia desde
américa ellos pueden realmente inclinar
la balanza
honestamente no creo es decir 100.000
personas somos no sé cuántos votantes
somos en total pero imaginaría que si
son más yo les dejo ese dato 48 7
millones de electores están registrados
en estos comicios de este año ni
siquiera llegamos al 0.1 es muy poquito
de pronto si dos candidatos están
empatados
al final de la jornada de la segunda la
segunda vuelta posible que si es 0.1 por
ciento en el impacto pero realmente es
más es más para la votación la votación
de los fans es como yo que viven en el
exterior es más una cuestión de darle
acceso a sus derechos a todos los
franceses a pensar dónde viven que para
realmente tener un impacto significativo
en el resultado final